hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
with Amy the castle amy castle knots is
here Amy the castle move over the rock
castle rock it see me castles her
YouTube channel go follow her there
Instagram Twitter it's Amy castle you
best believe I follow her she's one of
our featured channels on the real
rejects page so make sure to do it I'm
telling you I'm telling you hey have you
ever wondered about wheels transition I
don't care Wonder Wheel a Woody Allen
film every once in a while Woody Allen
is hit or miss let's find out what's
going on here he brought sexy back
gangster
[Music]
this can be out here right now
expecting lightning storms you're
married to a man who got rich putting
people's feet and then you probably
never had to do a dish want the like to
go fishing anymore she made like she
liked it hugger you know she's a marked
woman kiss you why are you getting so
heated I bet a fight everything's coming
apart
[Music]
interesting castle yes
I know what it is you're being a little
melodramatic
[Music]
Wonder Wheel Woody Allen's Boardwalk
Empire
I mean it's Justin Timberlake's I'm
going to go see it that's the main main
appeal yeah coloring of that movie looks
really cool I gotta say for a Woody
Allen film this might be his best
looking film I've seen him do yeah I
mean it's a period piece and he's really
brought the production how no he doesn't
do the production as I himself of the
production design is enhanced here yeah
Coney Island
this is Boardwalk Empire do the mob and
everybody yeah yeah yeah the cast is
cool that's interesting scene I mean you
hear Jim Belushi and a Woody Allen film
your first thought is comedy right right
no you're getting like this serious see
my mob tail mystery mob yeah done it
thing yeah and I actually you know I
might get a lot of flack for this but
I'm not the biggest Woody Allen fan of
his comedies there's something that I
really do in love a lot but in recent
years I it's really hit or miss from
when it comes to his comedies I think
his dramas are pretty consistent but I
wouldn't guess this is a Woody Allen
film based off the trail I feel a lot of
the time looks or anything yeah normally
I see it what do you on trailer I'm like
yeah it looks like a Woody Allen movie
right this is the first time I can think
of where I'm like this doesn't look like
a what do ya mean the closest thing I
can think of that is his style of this
is Midnight in Paris but that was a
straight-up romantic comedy yeah period
piece yeah this this is borderline
dramatic epic tale I'm definitely
intrigued by I'm excited I mean Kate
Winslet she's good I love her do you ask
the holiday I loved it look and that's
it right she doesn't do anything else
satanic or anything yeah she wasn't
revolution I will say I'm still standing
by my first comment it's got just
interpret just it really is a
surprisingly great
it's surprising to be like you got
Justin Timberlake in Jim Belushi in here
and you your first thought was Yellin
you're like it's gonna be a comedy yeah
it's not a comedy like he can just do
anything I like that he's taking on
roles that kind of stretch him more in
ways that we would not have experiencing
and also the dialogue every everything
about it seems like it's very tasty I
feel like with Woody Allen comedies they
all sound like a woody allen comedy this
dramas I feel can have more distinct
dialogue yeah the character some more
specific voices and the style is
definitely unique I'm pretty interested
in this actually you know and it's
coming out late November so I'm for
pushing for Oscar season right here get
it in right before the debut a rep for
the deadline and I wonder why they're
focusing on this wheel this ferris wheel
this is the Wonder but in the first
wheel I have I don't like them you don't
like them know what I like to do is go
on Ferris wheels with girls I'm dating
and we're in the top I go terrible Greg
good right the first time we hit the top
so it's just an awkward uncomfortable
ride today's page for the day shout-out
is gonna go out to none other than Matt
beer Matt beer I've talked to on Google
Hangouts he is a man with a lot of movie
knowledge and I'm sure he's a huge Woody
Allen fan
the thing about Matt beer of why I
wanted to give him a shout-out for
Wonder Wheel is because he seems like
the kind of guy who would ride a ferris
wheel alone I could see him falling in
love with a girl getting rejected and
then riding a ferris wheel alone I like
to give very positive inducing
empowering shoutouts for the patrons if
you're alone drinking alcohol on a
ferris wheel I can assure you that that
is what you're meant to do your whole
life your whole life there's never ride
with a woman on a ferris wheel and that
is not entirely your fault
but the part that is your fault is the
primary reason why you're not on the
I'm kidding I'm kidding you get girls
all the time who tried that we all
interested in chat out to you buddy
subscribe to the real rejects a
notification bell it's Amy castle on the
Amy castle channel go check it out do
live streams I do food videos to do it
all one day she'll put up the video I
did kinda shot months ago it's a it's a
long work in progress full production is
done on this video and so I understand
I'm gonna get it right in for the
[Laughter]